[Musique]
bienvenue dans ce set 8 sociétés spécial
professionnels oui de temps en temps
vous présentera comme ça des métiers
avec des gens qu'ils exercent et vous va
compenser par une profession évidemment
dont vous pensez peut-être savoir
beaucoup de choses mais dont on ignore
aussi beaucoup de choses c'est la
profession d'avocat et pour en parler
je suis avec mettre stéphanie gauthier
bonjour vous êtes avocate au barreau de
versailles vous êtes membre du conseil
de l'ordre
et vous n'êtes que tout spécialiste du
droit de la famille tout à fait maître
frédéric champagne
bonjour vous êtes le bâtonnier de
l'ordre de versailles cet avocat au
barreau de versailles le pénaliste de
taux si je prends un fan de polar oui
absolument
1 et vous êtes à la tête donc des 750 à
2 758 qui composent le barreau de
versailles et et votre mandat évidemment
a commencé avec la grève des avocats et
covile donc c'est pas c'est pas bâtonnat
de tout propos ou de samantha qui a
commencé sur les sur les chapeaux de
roue on va aux paris hector date choisie
bonjour bonjour vous êtes avocat
vous êtes numéro de top 405 je crois
tout à faire qu'est ce que ça veut dire
c'est dire que mon vestiaire dans la
salle des casses des avocats elle met au
405 d'accord et vous êtes vous êtes
installé à votre
à votre compte vous êtes vous avez
ouvert votre cabinet d'avocats vous êtes
pénaliste et vous avez été secrétaire de
la conférence du stage c'est en 2018 je
crois en 2010 9 au 19 et vous nous
expliquer ce qu'est ce que la conférence
du stage
mais d'ailleurs vous n'êtes pas le seul
puisque en visio avec nous il ya trois
jeunes avocats les lits chahid nouraï
bonjour vous êtes vous avez prêté
serment je crois en 2016 et vous êtes la
présidente de la commission jeunes
barreaux donc vous êtes une jeune
avocate du barreau de versailles à vos
côtés gabriel de groissiat bonjour
bonjour vous êtes vous êtes aussi avocat
vous est aussi secrétaire de la
conférence du stage de la même façon
20110 clown est pas le chanteur 1
absolument je changerais a lieu je
motive mais vous avez une très belle
voix puisque ben vous aussi vous avez
vous êtes secrétaire de la conférence
des stages de 2019 de manque un peu de
respect à hector qu'il était en vol vont
vous et vous aussi vous êtes à la fois
généraliste pratique droit du travail le
droit de la famille et le droit pénal
on va parler un petit peu de ce métier
avec vous trois avec vous trois et avec
nos trois invités qui sont en plateau là
on va peut-être commencer par cette
question comment et pourquoi on devient
avocat je commençais par vous m goûter
vous avez toujours voulu exercer ce
métier
étonnamment oui en fait depuis toute
petite photo de petit nom reste en
troisième
ah oui ouais quand j'imagine être avocat
au début c'est un rêve un peu lointain
plusieurs accès de très très loin ce que
j'ai départ moi aussi je travaillais à
l'école mais pas super gt pas la
meilleure de la classe quoi
c'est là
là la règle pour moi la règle doit
s'appliquer quand on devient avocat rend
compte qu'il ya des règles et à son
pouvoir forcément appliqué ça c'est
compliqué oui oui ça s'appelle la
jurisprudence appel on va pas les voix
il ya les dégâts les jugements de
tribunaux m sans panne vous avez hésité
trois autres magistrats et avocats
n'étaient pas forcément pas le jeu quand
j'ai intégré la faculté de droit orléans
je ne t'ai pas encore complètement
décidé et puis c'est au gré de deux
lectures de rencontres que j'ai opté
plutôt pour pour le métier d'avocat
celui de magistrats mais c'est vrai que
j'ai j'ai hésité en tout cas au départ
c'était assez ouvert je ne serai pas
exactement vers quel qu après man on
affine les guérir zenagui passe on
affine son séchoir le directeur la
vanille
moi je suis rentré un jour que j'étais
vêtue dans une salle d'audience
correctionnelle j'ai vu un prévenu dans
le box qui avait ni famille ni avocat
pour le soutenir
cela m'a vraiment donné envie de
soutenir les pauvres gens qui étaient
dans le box
et depuis cette rencontre j'ai essayé de
devenir avocat j'ai réussi
l'église par exemple vous et de vous
raconter comment est venue votre
vocation
alors je viens d'une famille de juristes
la croix bleue je porte mes initialement
le psychologue et finalement je crois
qu'avec le métier d'avocat suite on en
droit de la famille on les olé tous les
jours et donc j'ai suivi le chemin
parentale est assez en même temps et de
mes passions qu'il est d'accord
vasseur est clos alors moi je viens
d'une famille pour le cours de
militaires et ingénieurs ont créé aucun
juriste dans cette famille mes
hésitations au début après le
créé le buzz avec les études de droit
sont parfaits pour patienter et de même
façon que monsieur bâtonnier des
rencontres et puis aussi un certain goût
pour la littérature
il ya dans cette profession une passion
pour les histoires individuelles
s'exerce chaque jour que c'est passé
c'est là que ces essais jouer ce ce
choix c'est par ce biais l'inde et
gabriel de broissia au maire voulait que
je devienne prêtre et je n'étais pas
assez dans les bonnes grâces du senior
dont j'ai décidé de changer croit ben
voila c'était une question de rome est
ce qu est ce qui est des grandes figures
les uns les autres
il ya déjà des avocats médiatique
évidemment veiller des avocats peut-être
qu'on connaît moins mais qui vous ont
marqué des gens qui vous ont inspiré
pour pour exercer cette profession m
champagne a montré clairement alors sur
les sur les figures emblématiques
contemporaine quelqu'un comme henri
leclerc par exemple qui peut évidemment
susciter des vocations qui a chuté alors
c'est si on prend je sais pas si on
parle des avocats le nom d'henri leclerc
revient très souvent on le sait vraiment
il est l'incarnation de 20 pour les
pénalistes un pénaliste effacé 2 2 de
toute évidence j'ai eu la chance de
partager un dossier avec lui j'étais
alors jeune collaborateur du cabinet qui
l'employait c'était remarquable de
travailler aux côtés de la confrères
tels que celui là est également une
lecture leurs confrères plus ancien que
d albert noth le vivre les défendre tous
ri quand j'étais jeune oui c'est vrai
qu'il ya des livres comme ça qui peuvent
inspirer un objet d'aider des carrières
hector mais moi j'ai eu la chance de les
leur avocat me jean yves liénard vieux
je crois en un des plus grands plaideur
de versailles de versailles mais je
pense que c'est un ego plus grands
pénalistes français quelqu'un de très
attachant qui voulait partager sa
passion auprès des jeunes et ça m'a
beaucoup inspiré en tout cas stéphanie g
par personne en particulier
non c'est vraiment une fonction
peut-être peut-être que là il ya une
différence
vous allez nous dire aussi autres les
pénalistes et et parce que
d'abord quand on parle des figures
d'avocats c'est souvent souvent des
pénalistes souvent des gens qu'il plaide
souvent des des gens d'action amoureux
du mot aussi enfin un peut-être plus ce
qu'inspire plus sont peut-être plus des
pénalistes nom que les que les autres
sont tous les autres sont des grands
juristes vraiment je pense que vraiment
l'exposition c'est à dire
qu'effectivement il ya là il ya la
plaidoirie gagnent une place très
importante qu'elle est c'est la
plaidoirie à une forme de ce que
certains appellent la théâtralisation
mais comme les pâtes ans amelia
l'audience l'audience allait public les
choses qui la matière elle est souvent
spectaculaire un avocat alors qui va
intervenir la cour d'assises c'est
toujours dans des dossiers qui sont
exceptionnels par leur dans leur nature
à vous savez que vous avez cette phrase
de m florio qui est un grand avocat
aussi quand justement badinter a
supprimé la peine de mort et et de flore
y avait dit tu le métier parce que c'est
vrai qu'il y avait un enjeu évident
propre les avocats qui est vraiment
content devait couper la tête de
l'éclusé temps de ne pas avoir vu avec
toi parce que je pense que ces choses
les la personne pour qui ce travail et
mon patron a connu on lui a requise
on lui a requis par dont trois fois la
peine de mort dans son article dans
lequel de l'exercice professionnel et
que c'était quand même des choses assez
assez incroyable à vivre
rivoire il a dû assister dans des villas
les jamais été prononcé dans les
dossiers qu'il avait qu'il a eu à
traiter les déchets des liens quelques
temps mais il n'a jamais eu quelque
chose dans la même région
elle et les vous trois alésiens qui veut
s qui est des comme ça des figures
emblématiques qui vous ont guidé qui
l'ont inspiré en tout cas elles sont
nombreuses elles sont nombreuses par les
lectures d'abord je pense à à périers
enviro terres qui sont des dons on
conserve encore aujourd'hui des
belhouari entière sur les chefs-d'oeuvre
therapure ait eue s'il devait y avoir un
modèle voulu la part de ceux qui ont
déjà été cités sur le plateau qui ne
sont incontestablement je pense aux
bâtonnets bonne en agenais qu un père
clause de l'éloquence et c'est un
véritable bonheur de l'équipe brial
peut-être écoutez moi je pensais
tout simplement et andré damien litaud
masia l'atelier de versailles la chance
de rencontrer que lorsque j'étais jeune
et qui m'a beaucoup inspiré qui m'a
vraiment donné envie de faire ce métier
et les lycées une oreille alors t'es
peut-être dans votre famille vous tout
simplement que mais malheureusement je
vais devoir vous répondre mais
effectivement la figure paternelle était
quand même assez présente
après j'ai enfin d'université qui m'a
énormément marqué et donné le goût du
droit c'est le goût du droit à un
créatif ça peut paraître un peu étonnant
c'est que du riz qui ans par sa
bienveillance sa gentillesse et son
amour de la matière m'a donné je pense
en kit embrasser cette profession
d'accord on parlait justement les
pénalistes les autres s'est il ya des
spécialisations la plaidoirie c'est
quelque chose d'essentiel un avocat
c'est quelqu'un qui plaide forcément pas
il ya des avocats qui sont des
conseillers qui écrivent des dossiers
qui plaident pas mais est ce que le le
fait voilà deux alors c'est évidemment
c'est plus le paie ma main qui est
dangereux là dedans mais la plaie de
risque importants dans certaines
matières ça reste un élément important
de l'intervention de l'avocat dans
d'autres comme vous le disiez - les
avocats qui font essentiellement du
conseil qui font les a guidés et
activités juridiques puisque
juridictionnelle mais encore dans
certaines matières comme comme
évidemment le pénal mais le droit à près
de mal ce qui laisse une place
importante à la plaidoirie
on se sait pas c'est peut-être dans bon
nombre y compris dans l'activité
pénaliste et peut-être dans bons nombres
de moments d'intervention ça n'est plus
autant à un moment clé que par le passé
on va quand même de plus en plus vite
sur certaines sur certaines procédures
mais dans certains cas et notamment je
pense par exemple à la procédure
criminelle oui ça reste encore un moment
important
important de l'intervention vous
souvenez de votre première grande
plaidoirie
difficile ah oui elle et elle était oui
je m'en souviens c'était c'était dans
une dans la cour d'assises de renoir et
j'ai un souvenir partagé
c'est à dire que je suis pas sûr de
qualifier ça de bons souvenirs mais
serait à soutenir les mouvements ces
avant premières plaidoiries de cour
d'assises
et c'est vrai que c'est impressionnant
parce que les enjeux sont importants la
personne qui est dans le box on parle
pas d'une amende elle pas
d'emprisonnement avec sursis on sait que
ça va être un petit peu binaire et que
voilà les choses
jesús hama faisant gaffe voilà
maintenant ça passe ou ça casse là le
résultat a été mitigé
voilà c'était drogués à l'époque qui
avait pas d'appel il faut se souvenir
oui mais pas faire appel donc j'étais
dans une cour d'assises en perdant 6 et
c'est vrai que sans la possibilité de
faire appel il y avait ce sentiment de
2,2 de la deuxième chance d'en jouer
tout entre tous à la première pour les
audiences moi je me suis dit que c'était
à versailles que quand vous avez posé la
question de la première bonne plaidoirie
je ne sais pas si la première plaidoirie
forcément bonnes mais en tout cas on a
on a peur on a envie de bien faire parce
qu'effectivement mon avis de requis de
la prison ferme
c'était pas des excuses mais ça c'est un
jean que chez vous un petit peu de
réticences parce que vous allez en bien
envie de bien faire effectivement comme
ça se complaît prépare d'ailleurs on va
parler des autres fonctions des avocats
que le pédal b évidemment pour le public
et va il imagine toujours un procès
devant les assises et c'est très bien la
correctionnelle comment ça se prépare
parce que les avocats ou des notes mais
ils ne disent pas en hip hop et de riz
non normalement non non pas s'ils n'en
avoir pas si tu n'auras devant les
assises par louer le 8 juin
non le bes sas entre les white prépare
d'abord par par une connaissance la plus
exhaustive possible du dossier et elle
s'affine au fil de l'audience la cour
d'assises est une procédure qui est
luxueuse on a une instruction qui permet
de recueillir beaucoup d'éléments dans
kate et puis ensuite on a eu une
audience qui est la plus luxueuse
aujourd'hui parce qu'elle peut durer
plusieurs jours
et c'est au fil de l'audience également
parce qu'on nommait pénaliste sens c'est
qu'il y a un dossier à la cour d'assises
bien un dossier papier entre guillemets
un dossier théorique de cycle toutes les
choses qui ont été collectés jusqu'avant
l'audience et au moment du départ de
l'audience on sait que les choses
peuvent évoluer dans un sens comme dans
un autre
des points qu'on passe compenser minimes
deviennent majeurs des points qu'on
pensait majeur fille
c'est face à s'adapter il faut s'adapter
avec la plaidoirie vous la préparez
aussi au fil de l'audience il n'y a pas
pire qu'une plaidoirie qui seraient
préparées et figé qui ne s'adapteraient
pas à l'audience est un vrai risque de
passer à côté de la réalité du dossier
donc d'autant que vous parlez après
l'accusation après mon coeur qu'il faut
s'adapter aussi aux agathois ont
décidément d'arguments sur absolument
parce que quelquefois le président vous
mettre vous avez la parole depuis basse
et voilà le ministère public vient de se
rasseoir donc pas le on a généralement
cinq dix minutes de pause mais c'est pas
là qu'on fabrique la plaidoirie il faut
vraiment au fil de ses interventions des
autres des uns et des autres la partie
civile le ministère public pouvoir
affiner sa plaidoirie par de petites
touches l'audience elle exige justement
vincent et et gabriel le le la
plaidoirie c'est quelque chose
d'important d'essentiel pour vous c'est
plutôt le travail en amont du dossier
oui ça dépend peut-être aussi des ddd
domaines d'intervention dans lesquelles
vous intervenez écoute il s'est toujours
essentiel ça nous permet d'une part de
profilés nos écritures à l'oral et
d'avoir toujours une petite une petite
couche supplémentaire d'un petit
argument on n'aurait pas forcément dit
par écrit et qu'on va voir accentuent à
l'oral pour qu'on apprend de plus le
juge qui en fait l'ailé où vincent si je
peux me permettre je n'a que le droit de
la famille on est dans un petit cabinet
dans un petit bureau
face aux magistrats il ya un rapport
très fallait un rapport de proximité et
l'oralité permet justement de toucher
malgré tout on parle d' affaires
familiales de divorce de perdre devant
le fait de rendre concret réel par par
des mousses qui retrace la la réalité du
quotidien de la vie nos clients permet
parfois de tout chez le magistrat y est
de faire basculer une décision ce
dernier n'aurait peut-être pas pris à la
simple lecture en écriture
j'étais fatigué type d'accord avec ça
complètement d'accord la peau de rennes
n'est pas réservée au pénal
moi j'ai quasiment maintenant plus que
droit la famille même si j'ai fait un
peu de pénale du jura sociale c'est
important parce qu'on est au canon n'ai
aucun des familles au cas des choses
qu'on peut écrire moi je trouve que les
deux sont importants à l'écriture est
évidemment la plaidoirie mais comme je
le disais c'est d'expliquer au magistrat
un peu la vie de nos clients quand ils
sont là parfois c'est bien parfois c'est
pas bien non non parfois c'est pas bien
parce qu'ils savent pas c'est compliqué
pour eux d'arriver à une audience nous
c'est notre quotidien on a l'habitude de
d'être devant un magistrat devant un
bureau c'est leur première souvent là
vous parlez par exemple des gorges
par exemple à dire c'est effectivement
qui se présente devant le juge pour eux
ça peut être compliqué donc à des
dossiers ou moi j'aime bien qu'il soit
présent à mes côtés et il ya d'autres
dossiers où je me dis qu'ils les
préfèrent qu'ils ne le soient pas parce
que je sais que ça va être compliqué
pour eux on voir s'exprimer s'exprimer
surtout exprimer c'est patent s'entendre
ils savent ce qu'on va dire puisqu'on va
l'écrire préalablement mais en famille
la paix d'horaires reste importante ne
constate est important mais l'édile le
disait ça se passe dans un bureau oui
c'est à dire vous devez pas il n'ya pas
des deux ne veut pas avec des grands
effets de manche maintenant à en avoir
quand je crois pas qu'ils aient des
effets de manche à avoir en prendre à la
famille maintenant n'est pas tous les
bureaux quand on est en appel on est
dans une salle d'audience re donc là on
a pas on n'est pas la même configuration
mais est ce qu'on est vraiment dans des
effets de manche que moi je suis très
attachée au mot ne suis pas tant dans
l'expression
physique mais aussi tous parce qu'on
peut dire essayer de transmettre comme
comme message il ya donc une différence
entre le dgt aussi que vous avez écrit
parce qu'il ya beaucoup d'écrits danser
dans ces dossiers là et est ce que vous
dites alors normalement non parce qu'il
a quand même dit le président des ja
venons enfin pas sur le fond mais pas
sur le fond mais dans la façon dont va
avoir c'est un nouvel argument
évidemment qu'ils connaissent que la
victoire à respecter mais la façon de
l'exprimer peut-être oui dans l'émotion
dans parfois on est plus facile
oralement de d'expliquer une situation
et moti du client on n'est plus avec
nous ouais je viens au pénal des
quelques avocats comme ça qu'ils qui
disent moi je veux bien sûr et la
défense
mais je veux pas être partie civile deux
parties civiles et défend les victimes
un ok elle est un peu presque du côté du
procureur j'allais dire et il ya des
avocats qui le font mais c'est pas
l'heure c'est pas l'heure leur premier
élan vous comprenez ça pour vous c'est
un peu la même chose c'est un dossier
puis on défend des dossiers dois t'en
sais pas c'est pas ma façon de penser
moi je peux je pratique aujourd'hui
pratiquement à parts égales la défense
des parties civiles et la défense des
prévenus ou des accusés donc j'ai passé
de ce blocage qu'on retrouve d'ailleurs
en matière prud'homale vous avez des
avocats qui sont étiquetés entre
guillemets avocat employeurs qui ne
brille pas forcément salariés et surtout
les avocats traditionnellement salariés
qui ne souhaite absolument pas être
avocat employeurs et qui ont la même
vision je ne peux pas être l'avocat de
l'employeur ou je ne peux pas être
l'avocat du salarié en pénal vous en
avez effectivement qui très vite
privilégie en général d'ailleurs
soit un secteur d'activité vous avez des
avocats de victimes ou des avocats
partie civile qui ne veulent plus faire
de défense et des avocats de défense ils
veulent plus c'est un choix c'est un
choix c'est une sensibilité une
sensibilité personnelle qui se
retrouvent je crois dans l'exercice
professionnel ça peut être aussi lié à
un exercice antérieur qui est que ben on
est traditionnellement avocats de la
défense on a construit sa carrière
là-dessus et on comprendrait pas en
terme d'image oui oui on défend des
employés on a fait le reste
alors c'est vrai que chez les avocats de
la défense il ya souvent une espèce de
2,2 pas de mépris mais il peut y avoir
un seul est pâle et c'est vrai que ce
n'est pas le même exercice ceux qui
pensent qu on est du côté de
l'accusation ont à la fois raison et à
la fois tort on n'est pas accusateur des
freins on avait quand même les
défenseurs d'une personne qui se dit
lésé ou de proches d'une victime qui est
décédée
donc c'est pas il faut pas faire cette
confusion mais c'est vrai que c'est pas
du tout le même exercice
évidemment d'un point de vue ni même la
même pression parce qu'il est la mieux
préservée
donc voilà bon jour on a fait un peu tôt
de pourquoi pourquoi vous êtes devenir
pourquoi on devient avocat on va
s'intéresser maintenant comment on
devient aucun évidemment donc d'abord y
ait des études de droit
jusqu'à quel niveau se maîtrise ou c'est
en ça change tout le temps
c'est toujours le cas
c'est ma maîtrise et trois en un non
c'est qu'à 34 ans maîtrise n'existait
plus mais maintenant on dit master 1 et
il faut quatre ans pour présenter
l'examen et après il ya deux ans
quasiment deux ans d'école du barreau
donc dans l'idéal c'est six ans mais
dans les faits souvent les étudiants en
2 master 2 avant de présenter leasing
alors l'école du barreau sais comment
c'est quoi ces espaces ou alors en
l'état ça se passe alors ce sont
généralement des écoles qui sont
régionales il n'y a pas une école mais
des écoles qui sont à peu près réunis
par compétences de cour d'appel pour la
cour d'appel de versailles l'a l'école
du barreau qu'on appelle les dac elle
est située à viroflay
actuellement elle a longtemps été à
versailles met aujourd'hui à viroflay
et donc elle affecte effectivement une
scolarité qui est panache et de stages
concrets de stages pratiques et puis de
cours plus théorique mais ce qui se sont
quand même très axée sur des cours de
l'énergie sur des cours de rédaction en
conclusion une école qui va plus sur le
pratique que sur le théorique la théorie
temps censé acquise par les étudiants
qui arrivent avec un bac +4 ou +5 ya un
rapport qui vient d'être remis et je
crois au garde des sceaux kéké de
l'auteur sont révèles qui était doyenne
de la faculté de droit de verser 50 ha
qui demandait une une meilleure
formation pour les jeunes avocats
est ce que vous pensez de la formation
pas bonne moi je pense qu'elle est
perfectible
je pense qu'elle est perfectible pour
avoir pour être intervenu à l'école
nationale de la magistrature en
intervention actuelle j'ai constaté des
méthodes qui étaient des méthodes qui
moi me paraissait plus intéressante que
certaines qu'on suivait dans les
matières que je pratiquais mois à savoir
la procédure pénale ou le droit pénal
je je je ce sont des choses qui évoluent
c'est vrai que à une époque on avait
encore pas mal d'enseignements
théoriques qui aujourd'hui font quand
même de plus en plus place un
enseignement qui est quand même plus axé
sur le pratiquent plus accès parce que
c'est quand même le but c'est vrai qu'on
reçoit des étudiants qui ont encore une
fois un bagage universitaire qui est
important mais qui est théorique est de
la théorie à la pratique il ya
quelquefois un monde totalement en
fonction des matières ce fossé est
encore plus large que qu'ailleurs mais
réellement on peut on peut tout arranger
toute façon plus tout optimisé
c'est après c'est une histoire aussi de
moyens c'est une histoire de vent il
faut c'est aujourd'hui les écoles école
d'avocat est une école que je
qualifierais d'accessible financièrement
il faut enfin c'est payant oui il ya des
filles et des frais de scolarité absolue
alors ce qu'il faut mettre en face de la
réforme il faut mettre un coup et puis
ce coup savoir comment il est géré ce
qu'il est géré par les ordres pourquoi
pas ce qu'il est géré par les étudiants
pourquoi pas nous
je pense qu'il faut quantifier mais tout
est toujours perfectible je pense qu'on
pourrait effectivement faire un petit
peu différemment sur certains sur
certaines matières et puis on espère
dans le bon sens mais tout est
perfectible sous-effectif vincent l
aelies il est vrai de vous je vous
prends tous les trois ensemble à chaque
fois vous votre formation votre
formation d'avocat vous la trouvez
satisfaisante et des choses que vous
auriez des mairies qui s'améliore
l'information est très place de la
formation porte sur plein de domaines
alors il ya un domaine qui font
l'apologie sur lequel on a que ce
véritablement une école d'avocat puisque
les rapports avec les frères au
quotidien sont fondamentaux dans la
protection pour certains assez généraux
commandant les domaines qui matin c'est
mes spécialités enfin mais j'aurais
voulu utiliser mais c'est de toute façon
c'est quelque chose par lequel on doit
passer puisque les domaines du droit
sont elles m'ont phase amont nombreux
pour enseigner dans une école d'avocat
c'est assez normal et c'est vrai que ne
peut être inventé un petit peu plus dans
une avoir plus de grandir de syfy cité
pour pour donner des choix de spécifique
de spécialisation plus avancés aux
nouveaux jeunes avocats se serait
peut-être une manière de mettre la joie
dit entre la formation et puis le moment
où on devient avocat il ya il ya un
grand écart
oui pendant la pratique d'où les jours
dans le oui parce qu'en réalité quand
vous arrivez et que vous prêtez serment
il ya un ancien bâtonnier qui avait
coutume de dire qu'on ne savait rien
faire moi je pense qu'il a en partie
raison dans la mesure où ce qui vous
apprend réellement le métier d'avocat
c'est votre stage final c'est
éventuellement votre stage que vous
faites au parquet
mais quand vous êtes à l'école d'avocats
quand vous êtes à l'université même si
par exemple les cours en école d'avocat
aller daxon moi je trouve très bon même
si son très bon ça ne vous apprends pas
la réalité du métier
comment est-ce qu'on gère un justiciable
qui n'est pas content comment est ce que
quand vous êtes collaborateurs vous
apprenez à faire cinq dossiers en une
après-midi quand vous préviens à 14h30
14 heures voilà il vous voyez c'est de
la pratique c'est de l'empirisme et on
pourra jamais la prendre à mon sens dans
une école d'avocat ou à l'université
mais ce que je regrette c'est qu'à
l'université le l'examen du barreau
il est très très théorique on a d
accueil des étudiants qui sont très très
bons scolairement parce que la sélection
se fait sur les écrits et qui après on
peut être une intelligence à l'oral qui
est un petit peu un petit peu différente
et aujourd'hui et des très bons
étudiants qui n'arrivent pas à devenir
avocat à mon sens à mon avis parce que
scolairement ils sont au moins bon alors
qu'en réalité c'est pour être très bon
avocat je trouve que la formation est un
petit peu trop scolaire du moins à
l'université qui donnent les cours dans
les écoles de vote assez des avocats et
des pages de droit où il décroche de 9
en chine intervient
allez dac d'ailleurs on fait une
intervention avec dans son enclos
normalement en fin de journée à l'eda
que sur la sur la plaidoirie des
magistrats des professeurs d'université
s'est diversifiée y compris des
professionnels d'ailleurs d'autres des
enquêteurs on assure de vraiment
chercher ses multiples riels vraiment la
formation est plurielle mais en fait on
pourrait d oise art il ya des études de
droit qui sont assez théorique les
études d'avocat dans un peu plus
pratique et puis le métier qui est
encore plus voilà on met les mains dans
le cambouis carrément à c'est un peu ça
faisait un nom c'est ça en fait il ya
une réforme là la formation d'avocat
questionnent souvent parce que à notre
époque
enfin à mon époque en tout cas on avait
un an des pool d'avocats et ensuite on
était obligé d'avoir pendant deux ans à
un centre de maître de stage et c'est un
peu l'école du les codes de la vie est
là en étant un cabinet on était obligés
d'avoir un maître de stage qui nous
explique un peu comment ça se passait et
je trouve dommage que ça a été supprimé
ouais parce que l'école aujourd'hui
c'est 18 mois il ya des stagiaires et
guimond mais ça remplace pas ça remplace
pas le terrain tu as raison c'est sûr
c'est un cabinet qu'on se rend compte de
tout gérer un client de de faim tout
tout ce qui se passe dans la profession
quoi ces dommages là j'accueille
geoffrey meyer qui vient de nous
rejoindre bonjour je vous remercie
beaucoup
vous êtes vous êtes également au badge
en avant que vous êtes également
secrétaire de la conférence du stage et
est justement
ben voilà qu est ce que vous avez trouvé
qu'une grande différence puisqu'on en
parle et de cette question là entre le
moment où vous avez passé le cap à
celles capables toujours s'appelle
toujours qu'à part toujours ça va
changer ça et et le mot bon vous avez
à exercer pour la première fois votre
votre métier oui nécessairement c'est
vrai quand on ressent quand même de
manière assez sensible la différence
qu'il peut y avoir entre eux l'aspect
peut-être parfois un peu trop théories
de l'apprentissage de la profession et
l'exercice même de la profession qui
nécessite quand même pour ce faire
correctement une certaine expérience et
c'est vrai que l'on sent vraiment le la
réelle différence qu'il ya entre eux ce
qu'on peut apprendre à l'école les
enseignements qui nous seront dispensés
et les aspects pratiques de la
profession est ce que nécessite comme
expérience
l'exercice de la profession d'avocat
c'est un concours enfin le cas pas au
fond enfin c'est un examen mais il ya
combien de
c'est quoi le pourcentage de deux reçus
ont il est très important
l'important je sais pas quelle clé pour
chanter inter que ceux qui vivent ce
qu'il faut c'est deux ans de sont
motivés aussi évidemment pour surmotiver
quasi assuré de deux catégories vraiment
là assez déçu par est de ce fait
vraiment à l'apport de l'école et je
trouve qu'il n'est pas que c'était un
petit peu en croit belize et parce
qu'officiellement ce quiz versailles
saint quentin
chaque année il y avait exactement le
même nombre d'adrs nuit et on me disait
que c'était pas un concours mais quelle
que soit inscrit il avait exactement
d'ennemis chaque année donc c'est le il
ya un côté un peu un peu concours
déguisé est-ce qui est trop d'avocats
sans doute pas sans doute pas moi je je
je
c'est vrai qu'on peut avoir ce réflexe
en se disant l'ami 1 750 avocats
on est à peu près 4000 sur le ressort de
la cour d'appel avait qu'un en terre oui
on toiser et chartres paraissait énorme
génome sur la moitié du barreau français
c'est un chaouchi d'entre elles et entre
25 et 30 millions a dit enfin déclaré
lancement voilà c'est la moitié du
beurre aux français mathématiquement
pratiquement pratiquement chaque année
entre d'avocat je sais pas les domaines
sont multiples peut-être que la
profession est un peu frileuses à
réfléchir à explorer d'autres d'autres
sphères d'intervention à versailles on
essaie de développer notamment avec la
participation de la commission dont
stéphanie que tu fais partie le tout ce
qui est mode alternatif de règlement des
conflits avec les tout ce qui est
médiation en médiation à la préservation
de son des secteurs sur lesquels les
avocats sont encore un petit peu un
petit peu hésitant et regardons mais
mais je pense que c'est quelque chose
qui va se développer alors trop
d'avocats je sais pas moi depuis que
devrait bientôt faire trente ans on ne
cesse de me dire non l'organe a bien
trop parce que les gens vont tous partir
en retrait puis en fait ils traitent que
ça fait 30 ans et est la démographie
on a deux de femmes qui participent à
cette émission c'est leila chahid nouraï
êtes-vous stéphanie gauthier il ya une
féminisation de la profession
alors je sais pas si on peut parler de
féminisation j'ai l'impression qu'il a
toujours été
alors je me trompe avant ça fait 20 ans
que j'exerce j'ai toujours l'impression
qu'il y avait un autre homme oui mais là
ya pas une majorité de femmes si amusant
dorénavant 65 65 % de femmes et c'est
plus encore à l'école d'avocat et si les
magistrats aussi les magistrats c'est
80% de femmes à l'école nationale il
sera dur est tendance que commence comme
on explique ça vous avez une explication
oui d'abord dit non mais c'est peut-être
que là est ce que les femmes ont plus le
sens de la justice que les hommes n'ont
plus que vous disent peut-être la chose
juste donc je ne sais pas j'en sais rien
je sais pas non plus mais en tout cas
bon c'est une c'est une réalité alors
racontez nous peut-être hector mais
aussi les lie
vincent geoffrey et gabriel comment ça
se passe pour vous alors je crois que
vincent hectos vous êtes installé vous
avez ouvert votre cabinet 1
tout à fait après avoir travaillé dans
un autre cabinet césar moi j'ai fait
j'ai été collaborateur du bâtonnier
danton pendant trois ans ouais et ou
trois ans je me suis installé j'aime
tous mes propre cabinet qui exerce
principalement exclusivement d'ailleurs
en droit canal d'accord et ça veut dire
quoi vraiment pas gagné c'est d'abord
c'est des frais non c'est bien ça veut
dire que vous n'avez aucune garantie ce
tiers que vous cantonnez avant vous
étiez salariés vous êtes et ça se passe
et comment alors c'est officiellement ce
n'est pas du salariat on n'est rien
indépendance dire que votre patron votre
avocat patron vous lui faites une
facture c'est un de vos clients
donc dans les faits c'est toujours un
plaisir de tous un petit peu du salarié
ne va pas dire ça parce que voir des
orifices dans les faits c'est un petit
peu du salariat déguisé
mais en réalité quand vous créez votre
propre cabinet bien là vous n'avez plus
de revenus assurés par un avocat patron
vous devez effectivement vous et vos
locaux et avoir vos propres clients donc
c'est une démarche un petit peu
différente
ben ça c'est la même chose de l'été
collaborateurs une excuse et du droit du
travail exclusivement et j'ai pu
m'installer là récemment versé dans ma
cabine et qui fait et dans lequel je
loue un bureau qui fait lui plus du
droit de la famille et du droit pénal et
j'ai obtient de cabinet du coup à
développer ma propre ok d'accord les
livres vous êtes situation que l'instant
hector j'étais collaboratrice pendant
quatre ans je viens tu t'es un cabinet
qui exerçait principalement ce cadre mon
département droits de la femme et je me
suis hélas depuis le mois de septembre
où exerce principalement en droit le
droit pénal est d'accord et geoffrey et
gabriel vous vous êtes collaborateurs
dans des dans des cabinets existence est
absolument collaborateurs également en
2006 est en droit d
et vous vous pensez que vous allez un
jour c'est comme on dit volet de votre
vos propres ailes ou c'est en principe
c'est la logique de tout exercice de
profession d'avocat est vrai que
généralement le démarrage mieux que on
exerce d'abord un collaborateur et
qu'ensuite on fils alors soit devenir
associé du cabinet dans le coin des
cerces fois éventuellement créer le
nôtre si cette perspective ne peut pas
aboutir
vous vous souvenez du premier client qui
est arrivé moi je ne sentais pas contre
souvenir parce qu'en réalité quand vous
êtes collaborateurs vous avez une
clientèle personnelle mais disons que
dans votre propre cabinet dans mon
propre cabinet non je n'ai pas le
souvenir je sais que c'est du bouche à
oreille que ça va c'est comme ça que ça
marche ça c'est du bouche à oreille aux
recettes ça dépend des cabinets
d'avocats mais en droit pénal c'est
quand même beaucoup du bouche à oreille
c'est c'est intéressant parce que à un
moment on a cru que la profession
d'avocat les affaires semblaient
beaucoup à ce qui se passait aux états
unis qu'il y avoir des gros cabinet il y
en a mais on a quand même l'impression
qu'ils en france il ya un mot qui qu'il
va bien avec l'avocat ces libertés quand
même nom et indépendant absolument mais
même si on est toujours un peu en tout
cas moi c'est une de mes préoccupations
c'est l'exercice purement individuelle
parce que c'est souvent ça fait souvent
associée en forme dans une forme de
d'isolement et de solitude et qui est
pas forcément un mode d'exercice ce très
confortable mais les cabinets qui se
regroupent pour des exercices
individuels au sein d'une même structure
c'est effectivement plus le tradition
que le le gros cabinets même si dans un
bar au voisin d'enfer on trouve ces
grosses structures très présente
oui c'est dur de se faire payer
[Rires]
le groupe b oui dix ans le temps fatigué
c'est bah j'ai fait que sur votre site
et vous vous disiez d'ailleurs c'est
très clair c'est combien
mais si me fait bien fait qu'on est
transparent derrière ça qu'on en parle
c'est très bien ben oui oui pour tout ça
parce que parce que je pense qu'ils
aussi peut-être enfin cesser les jo sont
des justiciables
peut-être un peu d'appréhension pousser
la porte du cabinet d'un avocat khaldi
qu'est ce que ça va me coûter la peau
des fesses le coup mais face à joues
bien sûr alors c'est vrai qu'aujourd'hui
le rapport sur ce terrain là c'est
toujours un peu compliqué le rapport de
l'honoraire entre l'avocat et son client
notamment dans certaines matières ont
parlé tout à l'heure de l'assistance aux
victimes
alors si mais même s'il ya de l'aide
juridictionnelle de droit dans certains
secteurs il na pas été compliqué de
demander à quelqu'un qui a déjà subi
quelque chose qui est déjà un vient vous
expliquer qu'il est la victime de
quelque chose que ce soit en pénal loyen
difficile d'aborder le sur le terrain
financier mais aujourd'hui ce rapport là
il est encadré notamment par
l'obligation qui pèse sur tout avocat de
d'établir avec le client une convention
d'honoraires qui prévoit au mieux le le
coup à envisager sur la totalité procède
plus à la procédure elle ça aide je
pense autant le justiciable aujourd'hui
que la wii c'est plus simple en que
c'est plus simple et plus transparent
j'ai regardé un peu vos systèmes vincent
et vous c'est presque de la pub que vous
faites vous vous êtes joignant 24 heures
sur 24 7 jours sur 7
si vous avez un problème pénale elle est
un peu d'échecs tort la méthode est
simple il faut il faut attirer aussi
mais je pense que c'est une question
d'attirer mais c'est aussi une question
de ce qu'on propose c'est qui un avocat
pénaliste qui serait joignable très
difficilement pour moi ça serait pas
forcément compatible avec l'exercice que
le justiciable lui demande qu'est ce
qu'on demande aujourd'hui à un pénaliste
pouvoir être joignable tout le temps
aujourd'hui je sais pas ce que font mes
confrères mais je crois savoir que tout
le monde donne quasiment sont joints
tout le temps et que quand quelqu'un
vous appelle parce que son frère est en
garde à vue qui soit 21 heures ou minuit
hé bien il a envie de pouvoir appeler
son avocat de le joindre et moi pour ma
part mon numéro de téléphone personnel
même
le téléphone professionnel et si à
minuit et demi j'ai pas été à mon
portable quelqu'un m'appelle je réponds
bah oui et est-ce que vous avez déjà eu
la trouille
parce que vous êtes pénaliste je veux
dire voit pas que on voit pas que le le
le le summum de l'humanité comme je
pense que c'est une question qui se pose
moi je pour l'instant je touche du bois
c'est ma vie n'est pas finie mais je
veux dire c'est que je pense que je
rejoins ce que le disait le bâtonnier
frédéric champagne c'est que la partie
au moment où les limites sont bien
établis avec le justiciable dès le
départ de savoir combien vous allez
payer votre avocat et pour quel service
pour quelle prestation ce que ça sera
pour la plaidoirie est ce que ce soit
pour la plaidoirie et l'aménagement de
peine est ce que voilà si on fixe et
bien ce que l'on doit faire je pense
qu'il n'y a pas de réelles difficultés
avec le justiciable puis en face de nous
notre jean patou est arrivé le le risque
le plus fréquent c'est surtout celui de
la pression c'est à dire que vous allez
avoir des clients qui vont être vraiment
souk en fonctionnant comme ça c'est à
dire qu'avec eux avec en toile de fond
il peut y avoir une petite menace mais
vous savez un jour mettre je sortirai
etc
donc il faut savoir le gérer il faut
savoir aussi se dégage et d'assistance
d'un client qui manifestement se trompe
de deux mêmes modalités dans l'échangé
humain mais ce qui est le plus présent
plus que la peur c'est ce sens le
sentiment de pression qui est requis
peut être dans certains dossiers très
très très importante les questions sur
l'exercice même du meti peut-être avec
vous stéphanie gauthier autrefois il
fallait chercher dans les dalles aux les
machins palais des arts et aujourd'hui
ça s'est beaucoup informatisé c'est plus
simple d'avoir accès par exemple
décisions jurisprudentielles c'est
beaucoup plus simple
même si moi je repars très attachés au
papier évidemment que c'est beaucoup
plus simple d'aller chercher une dixième
il ya des moteurs de recherche de soasta
vrai qu'ils sont très bien qui facilite
les oui oui ça facilitera my way maman
non c'est bien voilà la profession
réfléchit beaucoup à tout ce qui est
avec les gens c'est artificiel pour
fournir des produits de plus en plus
perfectionnés dans les recherches et
certains produits aujourd'hui sont très
élaborés
mais c'est vrai que même nous on a mis
on à l'ordre met à disposition
l'ensemble des avocats un abonnement qui
est communautaire pour que chacun puisse
avoir accès à une bibliothèque juridique
dématérialisée d'accord justement sur
cet exercice de la profession
vous disiez mans vous êtes vous êtes
toujours tout jeune avocat donc vous
voyez pas d'évolution mais il ya une
facilité pour vous enfin deux voilà
d'avoir accès aux grandes décisions qui
sont nécessaires à connaître qui veut je
me lance oui effectivement c'est vrai
qu'alors nous ne devons pas connu les
anciennes modalités de l'effectuer des
rangers jouaient les deux pays notamment
dans les livres même chose comme ça même
si moi je le pratique encore parce que
de ma consoeur stéphanie gauthier très
attachés au papier mais c'est vrai que
nous avons grâce forment qui mène aux
plateformes de recherche nous permettent
d'avoir accès facilement à la fois et
que je le voie aux deux articles de
doctrine et la jurisprudence
peut-être devrait faciliter aux
recherches notamment leur est rendu dans
leur infinie et qu'on n'avait pas nos
prédécesseurs dans les années dans les
années antérieures et pour rebondir
également sens que le disait le badge ni
frédéric champagne monsieur le bâtonnier
il y à la profession a mis en place une
nouvelle méthode facilitation de nos
exercices pense notamment en matière
pénale parce que jusqu alors ils étaient
parfois qui par délivrer des procédures
il fallait courir en les grèves aller
courir en les services de reproduction
pour obtenir une copie de procédure ce
qui est parfois assez complexe et un
nouveau un nouvel outil a été développé
et mis en place en interaction avec les
la profession et les services de grève
pour qu'on puisse se faire communiquer
sur une plateforme sécurisée des copies
arrêter ce qui facilite grandement
les échangent leurs qualités et surtout
leur célérité ce qui est quand même un
gain notable lorsqu'on exerce lorsqu'on
exerce sans avocat alors je reviens à la
formation vous êtes vous êtes trois
quatre secrétaires de la conférence du
stage je crois alors moi ancien août
avant siens absolument c'est quoi la
disait la conférence du stage alors la
conférence du stage parle sous le
contrôle du bâtonnier champagne mais
c'est un concours de pour le résumer
succinctement c'est un concours de
plaidoiries des jeunes locaux
d'éloquence pour parler plus précisément
dans les grands barreau je pense au
barreau de paris à lille dans un certain
nombre de bars ou notamment à versailles
donc c'est un concours d'éloquence entre
plusieurs jeunes avocats et les gagnants
sont primés et on
l'année suivante le bénéfice des
commissions d'office criminel c'est à
dire qu'il est d'accord sont commis
d'office par le bâtonnier de l'ordre
pour défendre quelqu'un qui serait
accusée dans une procédure criminelle et
ils ont aussi représenté le barreau
pendant un an dans les différentes
rentrées des barreaux dans lequel
seraient représentés le barreau de
versailles d'accord avec enfin le la
tâche de prononcer un discours à la
rentrée solennelle du barreau de
versailles qui a lieu chaque année
donc voilà sept cdc se plaint des alliés
qui l'est c'est peut-être des plus
éloquents en tout cas dans cette quête
surreprésentation coco des jeunes
avocats pour ça l'as rome c'est
important oui oui vous ayez pas plaider
comme les américains quoique les
américains journée des perruques pour
les justes donc un nouveau jeu je suis
attaché je me suis alors peut-être pas
dans tous les secteurs d'intervention
intervient en garde à vue dans les
commissariats par exemple la non je n'y
apporte pas en do mineur mais en matière
disciplinaire on va choisir maison
d'arrêt intervient également pour la
matière disciplinaire mais j'ai tendance
à la m je trouve que ces voiles à ccc la
vie de nos professions puis c'est moi je
me sens mieux quand je suis avec ma robe
pour intervenir devant un magistrat que
l'action civile ne veut pas de la garde
à vue le fait que les avocats soient
présentes dans les gardes à vue ça a
changé beaucoup de choses de 12 à votre
vie oui c'est une vraie avancée elle est
parfaite elle est partielle parce qu'on
n'a toujours pas accès au dossier c'est
vrai que on nous réclame de pouvoir être
à même de délivrer un conseil utile
efficace aux clients et ça ça passe par
la connaissance du dossier où des
éléments d'enquêté pour l'instant c'est
un blocage total
on a un entretien d'une demi-heure avec
le client on a accès à certains éléments
on pourrait qualifier l'essentiel de
l'enquète mais pas tous et donc notre
notre marge de conseil et d aller
sensiblement réduite beaucoup de
pénalistes d'ailleurs font l'entretien
de 30 minutes avant le début de la garde
à vue et n'assiste pas le client ensuite
à faire pour éviter que leur présence de
vienne finalement une caution on dit
mais l'avocat était là donc monsieur ce
que vous avez dit et frappé forcément de
du sceau de la vérité
donc comme on est moi je sais que
assister à l'interrogatoire alors que
j'ai pas la matière pour savoir s'ils
n'exercent pas à ce moment-là 100 % de
la profession d'accord alors je vais
vous poser des questions que tout le
monde se pose sur l'aveu profession
d'avocat et faire des questions un peu
bateau mais bon voilà à la tête de veau
causé par les pénalistes à comment on
peut défendre d'aider les fournir et des
terroristes des baies comme le tunisien
qui a tué ses trois personnalise par
exemple fans et des absolue quoi
ces vues a cédé il ya beaucoup de gens
qui disent comment ils sont assez des
gens indéfendable je pense que d'abord
il ya toujours il ya toujours un moyen
de défendre quelqu'un savait pas dire
qu'on cautionne
évidemment ce qui a été fait on défend
le criminel on défend pas les crimes on
défend le le mais le délinquant est pas
le délit qu'il a commis il ya toujours
et puis ça bords fins et c'est aussi
pour ça qu'on est avocat si vous
défendez une des gens honnêtes
mais il ya toujours quelque chose alors
la marge on le sait vous donner des noms
des noms de deux criminels tristement
célèbre la marge d'intervention la marge
elle est faible mais elle existe et je
crois que le rôle et laissant sa
profession d'avocat et son rôle c'est
justement d'utiliser cette marge des
peut-être tenter lui a tenté de
réhumaniser quelqu'un qui est
déshumanisé aux yeux des autres c'est
pas toujours facile de voir les cités
dans le cas que vous avez cités c'est
sans doute pas facile mais il ya
toujours peut-être une petit à petit
quelque chose à dire attention puis
donner ici de de fournir le maximum
si on parle des crimes les plus graves
il se hisse se déroule aujourd'hui
encore malgré l'avènement de la cour
criminelle devant des jurés non
professionnels c'est aussi de faire
preuve de pédagogie au nom de au nom de
la défense en expliquant comment ça va
se passer en expliquant ce qu'on peut
trouver comme il faut comprendre avant
de juger et on est là pour essayer de
comprendre ce n'est pas là pour essayer
de justifier ce n'est pas la même chose
au récit est d'essayer de ne permettre
aux jurés de comprendre comment on a pu
en arriver là s'il ya des explications
y'en a pas toujours et de faire en sorte
que la personne soit défendu le mieux
soit jugé le mieux possible ce qui veut
pas dire encore une fois que l'avocat à
des routes ferment les yeux sur
l'horreur quelquefois de certains faits
qui leur sont reprochés
nous parler du livre d'albert nollet
défendre tous c'est oui c'était ça oui
oui et ses cessé vers l'ossétie voilà ce
sont ces en plus une histoire
particulièrement enfin une histoire
judiciaire des troubles est on est on
est passé pendant la guerre c'est
l'après guerre on a des des avocats qui
ont été résistants qui défendrait
collaborateurs elle est là enfin c'est
même si c'est l'outrance de l'histoire
mais le le l'avocat qui qui respecte son
serment il est présent là sous les
présents mais c'est vrai que ça fait un
peu surprendre ou déstabiliser quelqu'un
qui n'est pas un professionnel
on parle beaucoup du dépôt des listes le
dos mais dans le droit de la famille par
exemple c'est pas si vous découvriez
dans une procédure de divorce 1
marie do savait pertinemment qui bat sa
femme forcément oui
après c'est c'est aussi savoir la
compagnie moi je suis beaucoup aussi
dans développement des procédures
alternatives comme dit tout alors
monsieur le bâtonnier oui il ya des
considérations aussi donc on peut
envisager les fait différemment on parle
pas évidemment des violences entre
concubins on en use on n'est même plus
d'ailleurs endroit la famille on est
dedans près dans les différentes finales
mais on peut nous aussi défend les
positions que parce qu'on ne partage pas
des demandes peuvent être faites par nos
clients qui correspond pas à nos
demandes que nous on aurait pu faire
mais finalement on n'est pas l' on n'est
pas un modèle on doit nous accompagner
les clients dans ce qu'il souhaite donc
c'est d'abord déterminer clairement leur
besoin est arrivé à l'est à les mettre à
leur donner un mot juridique quoi on ne
savait pas dire être d'accord avec ce
qu'ils demandent notamment moi je vois
dans les organisations pour les enfants
parfois les choses qui sont qui me
paraissent aberrante et parce que c'est
ma façon de voir les choses
après il faut savoir s'adapter au
quotidien des gens et on peut ne pas
être d'accord allait défendre quand même
je crois que chez certains avocats
vergès 10 et 50 idées pour des barbies
mes dupond-moretti quand il est tard et
d'avocats ont santé ça aussi une sorte
de jouissance être seul contre tous
vergès disait voilà j'étais le seul
avocat l'effort de bach oui j'avais
cinquante autres en tout 24 de partie
civile face à moi j'étais seul face à
eux il y avait sept justement défendre
peut-être ce qu'on appelle
d'indéfendables ça ça moi j'aime bien
l'idée ici lima de la halle la seule
main tendue c'est à dire que quelques
fois que vous avez l'impression que vous
êtes même dans des dossiers de faible
envergure a simplement parce que l'effet
chantant tout bas ce qu'ils sont ils
sont pathétiques
parce que ils sont hélas vous êtes vous
savez que l'espace d'un instant et c'est
ça peut apporter une forme sais pas si
c'est de réjouissance aux deux
puissances mais une forme de fierté
d'être celui qui va dire pour écouter
c'est bien la partie civile a lâché est
lâché tout ce qu'elle pouvait dire sur
cet homme ou cette femme peu importe le
ministère public aussi l'instruction
d'audience a été faite un peu à charge
mais je vais être celui qui va dire
quelque chose qui va redonner à cet
amour et cette femme encore une fois le
sentiment que tout le monde ne le
rejette pas ouais ça je vous savez
quelque fois vous avez des frais même en
correctionnelle de la personne se lève
elle n'est pas détenu on est sur des
fictions pas grave mais qui sont eux
vous avez je pense notamment par exemple
un décès sur certains faits qui sont qui
sont à la fois pathétique vous avez
l'exhibition sexuelle par exemple et
vous avez ce monsieur qui va se relever
et on va donner son nom à donner son
prénom et il va devoir expliquer
pourquoi pathétiquement il s'est exhibé
devant même s'il fait il est pas du nil
et désagréable il est socialement
répréhensible et pénalement
répréhensible mais il va y avoir une
espèce de ça ne se fait pas et vous être
la seule main qui va accepter de se
tendre vers lui pour dire deux ou trois
choses il n'est pas seul ça apporte sa
une forme ça peut apporter une forme de
fierté pas toujours parce que c'est pas
toujours évident d'être le seul
quelquefois objectivement deux lignes
avoir des vrais sentiments de solitude à
l'audience s'il elles mêmes avant mais
ça peut être une forme de fierté et
encore une fois avec tout avec toute
l'humilité requis c'est à dire du du
petit dossier du quotidien aux gros
dossiers spectaculaire qui entre dans
l'histoire judiciaire du pays ou dans
l'histoire internationale comme le nom
que vous citiez tout à l'heure là je
peux comprendre que évidemment ce soit
décuplée mais au quotidien ça arrive
aussi mais on poserait pas la question
en médecins par exemple ça casse est
intéressant c'est qu'on lui pose
toujours la question à nous avocats
est ce que vous défendez rien n'importe
qui alors même que là je crois qu'un
jeune homme aurait essayé d'attaquer un
prêtre orthodoxe a lyon on n'a pas posé
la question de savoir si les médecins
avaient bien fait soigner ou pas le
l'homme qui ont été l'assaillant bassolé
il ya des gens crédibles mais pourquoi
le swing mais je trouve que la question
est choquant les mêmes choses
travaillées cassette défendre en partie
de vergès et de des dupond moretti
sorriso taux de feu te fais du théâtre
et on dit souvent voilà avocat se dit
être bien côté théâtral dans le dans le
dans l'exercice de votre profession un
moment ne va pas pas d'autres évidemment
pas que vous vous êtes seul dans votre
bureau collectif peut-être au moment où
s'exprime la rai dit peut-être oui oui
est ce que vous auriez maintenant dans
le bureau parce que l'on répète souvent
les pee wee une a évidemment un lien
avec le théâtre puisque nous prenons la
parole quand la parole en public
après il ya des différences
excessivement notable d'abord dans le
résultat ou dans le but
et puis et puis il ya dans le texte
puisque nous les qui vont ressembler les
porte-paroles de deux nous dit clients
et les clients le 15 mai un lien avec le
net il ya beaucoup d'avocats qui font du
tap
chose qu'il faudrait pas penser que ça
s'est adossé à un manque de sincérité
oui c'est pas assez c'est passer par un
jeu c'est pas un rôle de dire quand on
défend
effectivement il ya des points communs
je rejoins ce qui est dit mais où peut
jouer le rôle de l'avocat nourris y est
ce que je veux dire
sur jouer quelques jouer parce que voilà
c'est pas tout à fait naturel forcément
de s'adresser à des gens d'avoir des
effets ce qu'on appelle les effets de
manche était de jouer sur les sentiments
ça peut se comprendre c'est sûr mais
c'est je crois vraiment que en fait il
ya une vraie sincérité dans la rue non
mais y compris dans les faits deux
manches simplement parce que c'est un
talent qui s'exprime
vous allez avoir un avocat qui va avoir
une facilité dans ce qu'on peut
qualifier d'effets de manche même si
c'est quelquefois péjoratif un l'effet
de manche
on a le sentiment que c'est un peu d'un
peu de la poudre comme ça lance the
lancet devant devant un objet ou un
moment gênant du dossier mais il ya à la
différence du théâtre mais même s'il ya
des points communs il ya les costumes il
ya une forme de mise en scène parce que
tout le monde prend pas la parole en
même temps et n'importe comment
et on ne se tient pas n'importe comment
et on ne dit pas n'importe quoi et on ne
parle pas n'importe comment
il n'en demeure pas moins que voilà
c'est quand même la réalité c'est à dire
que ce qui va se jouer c'est pas c'est
pas une histoire ce n'est pas un texte
et puis surtout très souvent les
représente la représentation est unique
c'est ce qui souvent ce qui change avec
le théâtre c'est que si vous vous
trompez si vous passez à côté de votre
dossier lundi ben il n'y aura pas de
deuxième exigence quand même sur la
représentation unités oui il faut être
mon goût - le fait que l'un de vos
confrères soient soit garde des sceaux
c'est une bonne chose
oui oui objectivement oui parce que
c'est toujours en fait il est rassurant
que l'on considère qu'un avocat est
digne d'être garde des sceaux c'est pas
le premier dans l'histoire il y en a eu
d'autres
des gars au célèbre et d avocat célèbre
qui sont devenu garde des sceaux mais
c'est toujours vécu par la profession
comme un gage de reconnaissance sur le
sérieux et sur le canton demande à un
avocat d'être ministre c'est qu'on
considère qu'un avocat peut être
ministre document la profession s'est
toujours évidemment vécu comme une forme
de compliment général et vous comprenez
la guerre que lui font un peu les
magistrats justement
le garde des sceaux actuelle toujours
été tendre avec qu'on peut imaginer
blick
si certains étaient choqués le travail
et ont pu être surpris
et puis je pense que les choses rentrent
aussi un petit peu dans le rang c'est à
dire qu' il n'est pas ministre comme il
a été avocat j'aurais pensé que voilà
c'est non il s'agit bien du même nom
même physiquement je trouve de cause lui
même les costumes sont plus les mêmes il
est entré dans des costumes de deux
ministres il nous reste à peine deux
minutes et demie je voudrais qu'on parle
justement alors la fonction de bâtonnier
on l'a compris vous dirigez le barreau
de versailles dont on parlait des
difficultés qui ont été les vôtres
puisqu'ils lui la grève sur les
retraites et a eu la main trop vide
le deuxième profil mans il est il est
plus simple à gérer pour vous le premier
était terrible basse qui s'accompagnait
d'une cessation totale d'activité
judiciaire un peu de choses près comme
de tes années par l'ultra urgences plus
rien été traités ça a été très compliqué
d'un point de vue judiciaire d'un point
de vue social elle a un point de vue
financier soyons clairs le client dans
la sphère n'est pas jugé il s'empresse
pas d'aller chez son avocat
s'il peut y aller pour dire je vais vous
réglez la le le second jeudi je préfère
utiliser ce bon ça pourrait vouloir dire
qu'il n'ya pas de troisième mais en tout
cas l'actuel confinement il est
différent l'activité maintenu donc on
n'a pas le même il n'ya pas le même
stress les mêmes les autorisations
voyait des signes et des signaux
l'autorisation permet à un justiciable
d'aller chez son avocat s'il si pour
l'instant à un rendez vous bon c'est pas
du tout la même c'est pas du tout
économiquement je pense en tout cas que
judiciairement mme économiseront c'était
compliqué ah c'était très compliqué très
compliqué en pénal même activité à coup
tu aimes ou pelé n'a pas été compliqué
en droit de la famille par le pianiste
pouvait continuer à avoir les clients
s'étaient pas la même chose d'équipement
elle épuise audience donc et beaucoup de
renvoi mais on pouvait continuer à avoir
les clients - vision on a découvert des
choses
les moyens techniques pour pouvoir
poursuivre avec eux et les accompagner
parce qu'on a notamment dans la famille
on a quand même des familles qui se sont
retrouvées confinés ensemble et où les
tensions puis oui s'avérer de problème
voilà donc on on a continué à travailler
bien sûr c'était plus compliqué mais on
a continué à travailler comme écouter
merci infiniment
mais ce que je devrais avec champagne m
stéphanie gauthier est recteur lajoinie
merci beaucoup m 10 avril
vincent nicomette relie chahid nouraï et
m geoffrey meyer merci d'être d'être
d'avoir participé à cette émission là
j'espère qu'on doit donner un peu
peut-être blanc vie si vous deviez bien
quelqu'un qui est un jeune comme ça qui
vous dit j'ai envie de devenir avocat
vous lui dites quoi comme conseil il
faut foncer français y avoir quelques
désillusions mais il faut y aller quand
même
voilà hockey aussi allez on y va merci
infiniment merci infiniment à très vite
pour une bonne animation
[Musique]